مشاهدينا الكرام يمكن القول كما ذكرنا ان
هناك قدس تحت القدس هناك ثلاث عناوين
رئيسيه لانفاق والحفريات والمشاريع عندما
تحدثنا عن انفاق فنحن نتحدث عن 26 نفقا
داخل البلده القديمه وخارجها وطبعا هذه
الارقام ليست ارقام دقيقه لان الاحتلال هو
الوحيد الذي يتحكم بهذه التفاصيل ولكن هذه
ابحاث ودراسات للفلسطينيين ابرز هذه
الانفاق ونحن نتحدث عن بلده القديمه كما
نشاهد في الخريطه هذه البلده القديمه من
مدينه القدس التي تبلغ مساحتها حوالي واحد
كيلو متر مربع كما نشاهد على الشاشه ويقع
المسجد الاقصى المبارك في الجزء الجنوبي
الشرقي وتبلغ مساحته 144 دونم كما نشاهد
في الشاشه اذا ما انتقلنا الى صوره اقرب
للبلده القديمه وتحديدا محيط المسجد
الاقصى المبارك فنحن نتحدث في شكل اساسي
عن النفق الغربي لنتحدث عن 26 نفقا ابرز
هذه الانفاق هو هذا النفق الممتد من الجهه
الجنوبيه
الغربيه للمسجد الاقصى المبارك باتجاه
الشمال كما نشاهد هذا هو النفق الابرز
الذي يمتد الى حوالي 450 مترا تحت الارض
وعمقه حوالي 11 الى 12 مترا ايضا تحت
الارض هذا النفق الكبير الذي ينطلق من
الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه هذه الجهه
الجنوبيه الغربيه التي تشكل ساحه البراق
بشكل اساسي وينطلق نحو الشمال الفلسطينيون
هذا النفق بدا العمل به عام 1970 اي بعد
ثلاث سنوات فقط من احتلال المدينه المقدسه
وكان العمل ياتي ويذهب به سرا وعلانيه
والاخرى وهذا النفق ادى في عام 96 ابان
حكومه نتنياهو الاولى الى اشتعال ما عرفه
حينها بحبه النفق بعد ان اكتشف
الفلسطينيون امر هذا النفق واستمرت الهبه
الى سته اشهر وسقط فيها اكثر من 60 شهيدا
طبعا الفلسطينيون في عام في تمنيات القرن
الماضي اكتشفوا ان هناك انفاق
المسجد الاقصى المبارك تعبر من هذا النفق
الغربي ابرزها النفق الذي وصل الى سبيل
قائد باي في هذه المنطقه الجهه الغربيه من
مسجد قبه الصخره في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
اذا هذا ابرز نفق للاحتلال النفق الغربي
الذي يمتد بجوار الحائط الغربي للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك وكما ذكرنا ينطلق من ساحه
البراق ساحه البراق احدى ابرز المعالم
الرئيسيه التي تتعرض لعمليات حفر وتنقيب
وانفاق وفيها اجتمعت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هذا اليوم هذه ساحه البراق في هذه المساحه
التي نتحدث عنها الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه
من المسجد الاقصى المبارك وكما تشاهدون
على الشاشه الان هذه الخريطه ساحه البراق
ولكن ايضا كما تشاهدون في مقاطع الفيديو
على الشاشه هذه هي الانفاق التي وج
تحت ساحه البراق تحديدا المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه ونشاهد عمق هذه الانفاق كما نشاهد
على الشاشه الان تحولت هذه المنطقه الى
منطقه سياحيه بدرجه اساسيه يستعرض فيها
الاحتلال ما يعرف بتاريخ او ما يزعم بانه
تاريخ الهيكل في هذه المنطقه وهنا اجتمعت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه حكومه نتنياهو اليوم
في هذه المنطقه في الانفاق التي توجد في
ساحه البراق هذا هو باب المغاربه الذي
يدخل منه
المستوطنون
لاقتحام المسجد الاقصى المبارك من هذه
الجهه من الجهه الغربيه واقتحمون المسجد
الاقصى المبارك من امام المصلى القبلي
جنوبي المسجد الاقصى المبارك وينتقلون
شمالا في محيط مسجد قبه الصخره ويتجولون
ثم يغادرون لكن هذه المنطقه كما ذكرنا هي
ابرز المناطق التي تجري فيها عمليات
التنقيب والحفر في اكثر من مناسبه وهناك
يعني عشرات الام من الانفاق وعدد عدد من
القاعات التي تم اكتشافها في هذه المنطقه
الاحتلال او المقدسيون يقولون بان
الاحتلال خلال السنوات وكل عقود احتلال
القدس يحاول البحث عن ما يمكن ربطه
بالهيكل الاسرائيلي او الهيكل المزعوم كما
يقول الفلسطينيون ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم العثور على اي دلائل لربط موضوع
الهيكل بهذه المنطقه اذا ما انتقلنا الى
المنطقه بخريطه اوسع الانفاق خارج البلده
القديمه هذا هو السور البلده القديمه كما
نشاهد على الشاشه وهذا هو المسجد الاقصى
الذي تشاهدونه ولكن هناك انفاق تتركز بشكل
اساسي ايضا في قريه سلوان هذه القريه التي
تشكل الحاضنه الجنوبيه للمسجد الاقصى
المبارك تم الكشف ايضا خلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه عن عدد لا باس به من
الانفاق والتي بدرجه اساسيه قامت بها جم
الاستيطانيه ابرزها هذه الانفاق تاخذ عده
اشكال من عين سلوان تاتي وتذهب وتعود الى
المسجد الاقصى المبارك هذه الانفاق معظمها
تم
بعمليات قامت بها جمعيه العاده
الاستيطانيه وكنا اكثر من مناسبه سمعنا عن
جمعيه العاده الاستيطانيه التي تقوم على
عمليات احتيال في هذه المنطقه وتشتري
منازل من فلسطينيين بعمليات احتيال كما
ذكرنا وتسيطر على هذه المنازل لتقوم
بعمليات الحفر والتنقيب في هذه المنطقه
الكبيره قريه سلوان كما نشاهد على الشاشه
وهذه القريه التي تتعرض لعمليات تهويد
بشكل كبير خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه
اذا ما انتقلنا الى صوره اوسع نتحدث عن
الحفريات حفريات نتحدث عندما نتحدث عن
حفريات فنحن نتحدث عن حوالي 50 حفريه
تقريبا خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه
ابرزها في المنطقه الجنوبيه والجنوبيه
الغربيه بدرجه اقل في المنطقه الشماليه من
مسجد الاقصى ودرجه اكثر تقريبا بالوسط في
المنطقه الجنوبيه 50 حفريه في محيط الاقصى
وهناك عدد من المشاريع التي يصفها
الفلسطينيون ايضا بالمشاريع التهوي